und zugeschaltet begrüße ich jetzt
Margot Käßmann ehemalige Bischöfin und
Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen Kirche
von Deutschland sie gehört zu den
unterzeichnen des Manifests von Sahra
Wagenknecht und Alice Schwarzer guten
Tag
ich grüße sie bevor wir zur Manifest von
wanknecht und schwarzer kommen sie sind
heute Rednerin bei einer
friedensveranstaltung in Bonn was wird
den Kern ihrer Rede sein
dass wir als Deutsche
Friedensgesellschaft und andere Gruppen
aus dem christlichen Bereich ein Stopp
der Waffenlieferung fordern weil wir
glauben dass so dass Leid und der Krieg
verlängert werden und weil wir denken
eine Eskalation des Krieges nützt auch
den Opfern in der Ukraine nicht wir
wollen einen Waffenstillstand so schnell
wie möglich und dann Verhandlungen
sie haben das Manifest von Wagenknecht
und schwarze unterschrieben warum
weil mir wichtig ist dass es in
Deutschland nicht nur ständig eine
Diskussion um Waffenlieferungen noch
mehr Waffen erst Helme dann
Verteidigungswaffen jetzt angriffspanzer
und vielleicht auch noch Jagdbomber gibt
sondern dass die Diskussion sich darauf
konzentriert wie schnellstmöglich das
Töten in der Ukraine gestoppt werden
kann wir kommen gleich auf diese
inhaltlichen Aspekte aber zunächst mal
es gibt Kritik an Manifest weil auch
rechte Politiker wie der afd-vorsitzende
krupala das Manifest unterstützen was
bedeutet das für Sie
ich finde das tatsächlich bedrückend und
belassen auf einlassen dass oder damit
abfinden dass inzwischen die rechte
Szene rund um die AFD ständig
irgendwelche Aktionen Kapern will wie
beispielsweise schon bei den
corona-demonstrationen oder die
Demonstrationen gegen die Maßnahmen ich
habe damit nicht gerechnet aber ich
werde hier auch glasklar sagen wer für
den Frieden demonstriert kann nicht
Nationalismus befördern wollen weil
genau das ist ja im Moment in Russland
das Problem diese nationalistische
Haltung aber was bedeutet denn das
konkret sie unterschreiben das Manifest
dann sagt propala ich unterstütze dass
man fest auch die begegnen Sie den dem
Argument damit würden sie gemeinsame
Sache machen mit der AFD
also erstmal war das Manifest da und
dann hat Herr kropalla versucht sich
daran anzuhängen wir lehnen das glasklar
ab und wir haben von der Deutschen
Friedensgesellschaft noch einmal eine
Erklärung herausgegeben die sagt rechte
Kräfte leonazis die AFD haben hier
nichts zu suchen sie sind unerbeten
unerwünscht aber weil diese Menschen
versuchen die Bewegung zu kapern werde
ich nicht zu Hause bleiben und sagen
jetzt traue ich mich nicht mehr auf die
Straße und traue ich mir nicht mich
nicht mehr meine Meinung zu sagen gut
dann lassen wir uns über die
inhaltlichen Schwerpunkte des Manifests
sprechen
Gegner sagen die Angst vor dem Atomkrieg
also Gegner dies Manifest sagen die
Angst des Atomkriegs vor dem Atomkrieg
sei ein
Propaganda Trick Putins
ich
Rede irgendwo in Deutschland und wenn
ich am Ende die Hände schütteln an der
Kirchentür sagen mir viele viele
Menschen ich habe Angst ich habe
wirklich Angst dass dieser Krieg sich
ausweitet Menschen können nachts nicht
mehr schlafen gerade ältere die noch
kriegsgenerationen sind sehen diese
Ängste für sich jeden Tag und wir können
doch nicht einfach sagen weil Putin das
sagt dürfen wir nicht sagen es gibt
reale Angst vor einem Atomkrieg und das
können wir nicht einfach wegwischen ein
weiterer Einsatz übrigens auch lange
nicht
ja machen
[Musik]
damit sind wir noch lange nicht
putinversteher ich verachte diesen
Kriegstreiber der ja sofort das tun
könnte dass der Krieg beendet ist das
ist kein Putin verstehen sondern ein
Ausdruck von Real in Deutschland
existierende Angst ein weiterer Einwand
gegen das Manifest ein Waffenstillstand
und Friedensverhandlungen sein erst dann
möglich wenn sich Russland komplett aus
der Ukraine zurückgezogen haben
das ist natürlich eine Maximalforderung
die dann immer mit einem absoluten Sieg
der Ukraine verbunden ist ich kann das
sogar nachvollziehen und verstehen aber
meine Frage ist wie viel 100.000 Tote
soll es noch geben bis dahin und um der
Menschen will ist es doch wichtig dass
es jetzt sofort einen Waffenstillstand
erst einmal gibt und dann verhandelt
wird was sind die notwendigen Maßnahmen
das ist zufrieden kommt aber
Waffenstillstand sofort das muss doch
das Thema sein jetzt haben sie ja in
ihrer ersten Antwort auch dezidiert
Stellung genommen gegen
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine aber
dann wäre die Ukraine dem ergressor ja
hilflos ausgeliefert
mein Plädoyer ist das nicht wir
versuchen als deutsche gerade immer mehr
Waffen zu liefern wir haben als in
Jahrzehnten als Deutschland gesagt wir
liefern keine Waffen in Krisen und
Kriegsgebiete und ich fand das aus
unserer Geschichte heraus eine wichtige
und gute eine elementare Position dass
das einfach über den Haufen geworfen
wird dafür müssen wir uns als deutsche
doch verantworten und ich finde der
Philosophie und Habermas hat das sehr
gut gesagt damit sind wir auch für das
Töten in der Ukraine mitverantwortlich
die Außenministerin sagt unsere Waffen
schützen Menschenleben das stimmt sicher
aber es stimmt auch unsere Waffen töten
Menschen ich darf mal das Aufgreifen
weil sie haben Maß gerade angesprochen
hat aber was hat von einem Dilemma
gesprochen aber er hat nicht gesagt wir
dürfen keine Waffen liefern gibt es denn
aus ihrer Ansicht aus ihrer Sichtweise
eine christliche Antwort auf dieses
Dilemma zwischen der Suche nach dem
Frieden und der Unterstützung für den
der offensichtlich angegriffen wurde
ich denke dass Christinnen und Christen
aufrechterhalten müssen was Jesus gesagt
hat steckt das Schwert an seinen Ort und
versucht ihr in Frieden mit den Menschen
zu leben es ist aber eine
Herausforderung unsere Kirchen sind ja
auch gespalten es gibt eine Mehrheit in
den Kirchen die sagt Waffenlieferung ja
zur Selbstverteidigung es gibt eine
Minderheit in den Kirchen die sagt wir
müssen bei dieser pazifistischen Haltung
bleiben und wenn ich erlebe wie viel
Aggression im Moment in der Debatte ist
dann erwarte ich doch von einer
demokratischen Gesellschaft das ist
Respekt für unterschiedliche Positionen
gibt ich habe Respekt für diejenigen die
sagen dass nur Waffenlieferungen helfen
aber ich erwarte auch Respekt vor uns
die wir sagen als Pazifisten wir glauben
dass noch mehr Waffen diesen Krieg
verlängern dass jede Position und nicht
davor schützt schuldig zu werden ich
finde das müssen wir alle auch
eingestehen die wirkliche Lösung hat im
Moment niemand
jetzt haben sie ja mit ihren Antworten
klar gezeigt dass sie das Manifest und
seine Inhalte von Wagenknecht und
schwarzer und unterstützen warum sind
sie denn dann heute nicht bei der
Demonstration in Berlin
die deutsche Friedensgesellschaft hat
gemeinsam mit pax christi der
aktionsgemeinschaftsdienste für den
Frieden Naturschutzbund attack schon
Wochen vorher ein Bündnis geschmiedet
und gesagt heute wollen wir dezentral in
ganz Deutschland Aktionen Kundgebungen
friedensmärsche veranstalten da hatte
ich schon längst zugesagt hier in Bonn
und später auch noch in Köln und deshalb
bin ich heute hier innerhalb von diesem
Bündnis das ist die Position von Margot
Käßmann herzlichen Dank